Negative 1 is greater than negative 2, so we need a greater than sign. Let's
look at the two number lines for these two inequalities. Let's say that this
time, I want to see if the 2's are correct in relation to the 1's. So, I'm going
to draw these number lines from the perspective of the number 1's. So, I want to
know if 2 is greater than 1. That means it should fall in the category of all
numbers that are greater than 1. Start at 1 I need to shade to the right. Sure
enough here's 2, smack dab in the middle of that range, well not in the middle
but in it and that's all that matters. Now we want to know if negative 2 is in
fact in the range of numbers that are less than negative 1. Let's go over to
negative 1 and shade to the left of negative 1. And once again we have negative
2 as part of that interval. Awesome. Comparing these 2 number lines, looks like
we have pretty much exactly the same thing, except that the intervals here are
fractions of one another across the 0 mark. So if I match the 2 of them together
on 1 number line, can see that we have the exact same thing to the right of the
0 as we have to the left of the 0, just inverted. This is pretty cool. So,
dividing by negative 1 is just like flipping everything to the opposite side of
the number line. So, when we divided by negative 1, we flipped our point of
reference across the 0, the same distance away to the other side of the number
line. And that's why we had to switch our sign, so that it faced the opposite
direction as well. The two numbers now have the opposite relationship. Since
being further away from zero than another number on the positive end of the
number line means that you're greater than that other number. Whereas being
further from zero than another number on the other end of the number line; the
negative side means that you're less than that other number.